hello everyone and welcome back to the
magnus carlsen grand final it's the
other match and
the second game of the match magnus
carlsen versus dingler and the first
game ended by ding winning the game and
now magnus needs a win to get back into
the match and already
uh it's uh quite an interesting game i
skipped the first one first one was
there was a pretty pretty
straightforward win by ding
nothing out of the order ordinary there
uh
but this one is uh is a bit uh well
you'll see what i mean so magnus with
the white pieces opens with
d4 and we have knight to f6 but before i
show you this
uh i just want to show you uh one trick
that i've seen now eric rosen posted a
video on it i thought it was a really
really
funny uh a trap against the london
system if
if you know that someone plays the
london try to strap against them i've
seen that it works against uh well
uh very very high rated opponent so the
point is after d5 bishop f4
your opponent will try to go for the
london system but you try and trick them
with h5
and they'll they will be like what are
what's this guy doing they'll just
continue with their
uh london system set up and then e5 wins
the bishop
it's that simple uh point is that it
doesn't matter what you do here
if you go back then this just wins the
bishop if you first capture
then f6 you go back g5 go back and h4
now wins the bishop and it's uh not
different if you capture with the pawn
still just g5 here and this wins the
bishop so i thought
it it's really funny and if you're a d5
player if you uh face the london system
a lot
do give it a try this has nothing to do
with this game i just thought it was uh
really funny
so here knight to f6 uh we have knight
to f3 and d5 magnus goes for bishop f4
we do have the london system and c5 by
ding
uh we have e3 and now e6 we have c3
strengthening the center now that the
bishop has been
released from the cage and bishop d6
ding now offers a trade of dark square
bishops and knight b to d2 it's not a
problem you can you can allow this
straight even though it messes up your
pawn structure
you will have a firm grip of the of the
e5 square uh and here we have c
captures uh on d4 it's actually a new
move in the position
a lot of moves haven't tried here but
this early capture
is a new move so already as a move six
we have a completely new game
bishop captures on d6 first by magnus
but now a nice tuition two by ding
d captures an e3 asking magnus what do
you do now do you want to recapture here
and then i
claim the bishop or do you want to save
the bishop and i'm going to capture the
knight so magnus says
okay i'm going to go back with the
bishop because now
you will not be able to castle ending
says okay uh
e captures on d2 with check queen
captures and the knight the c6
so ding will now uh most likely uh
castle queen side at
uh it's very unlikely that you will be
able to do this so magnus immediately
goes queen g5
as if you don't then black might have
some ideas of going knight e7 blocking
the bishop and the
just castling so here queen g5 rook to
g8 by dean guarding the jeep
seven pawn and now bishop to d3 by
magnus with h6
pushing the queen back queen e3 and the
now queen to b6 offering the queen trade
magnus not interested he
is down a pawn so the queen back to e2
and now bishop to d7
ding is now ready to castle queen side
with castles king sideway magnus and the
castle's queen side by ding
and now as usual when we have uh kings
on opposite sides of the board
uh it's uh well very often a race uh and
it's uh
you know every temple count so here
magnus already starts pushing with
b4 next is he's going to move the bishop
play a4 hopefully
it's on like a b5 a5 and so on so here a
nice prophylactic king b8 by ding and
now b5 and this is a very nice move uh
because the knight doesn't really have
any good squares this is taken this is
taken by the knight and the queen this
is taken by the bishop
this is the rook is here so the only
square you have left
uh is the a5 square which is what the
ding plays and now knight to e5 as the
knight no longer guards the e5
square and now the bishop is being
threatened also the f7 pawn is under
attack
so bishop to e8 and now comes bishop to
b4 preparing to push the pawn
uh all the way to a4 uh we have rook to
c8 now here
carlson's plan is uh you want to push c4
at some point this this and this regards
the c4 square so c4 is coming you might
want to even prepare it with rook to c1
uh but it is coming uh so first we have
rook to c8 by ding
adding additional protection to the c4
pawn and now a4 before deciding on that
uh here we have knight the e for biting
giving up a pawn
but it's hard to it's hard to find a
move for being here nothing
nothing seems to be working as you can
you can simply
wait and see what will happen the knight
doesn't have
a good square to go to uh you could go
to b3 but the rook will just attack it
uh other than that
not really the the bishop cannot move
otherwise you lose this
the rule cannot move if the bishop
doesn't move so it is a very
weird position a nice queen c7 awaiting
move is probably the way to go for thing
but ding decides to go for an
active knight to the e4 it sacrifices
upon
in exchange for playing f6 uh he wants
to get rid of this strong knight uh uh
from the e5 outpost uh and magnus says
all right bishop captures we have
captures and now captures on e4 and now
f6 biting now
is this one of the positions where it's
actually okay to play f6 or not
uh feel free to pause the video and find
out for yourselves uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
uh you know a little hint it's
definitely not
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on spotting uh
the only winning idea for magnus here
and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show it's queen to h7
and it's a beautiful move uh because the
rook is under attack and you don't
really have all that many good moves
uh what what could you play here like
you could try
you could try something like rook to f8
but then the bishop just picks it up so
the rook
doesn't have any squares and the problem
is you can't really move the bishop to
connect rooks because this is covered by
the knight
and this is covered by the pawn so not
really and of course if you play
something like bishop h5
then just knight here uh checks the king
forks the queen and it's
game over so here after this uh f6 move
magnus indeed played queen to h7 uh
attacking the rook but now
uh for the lack of a better move ding
played knight to b3 he attacked
carlson's rook but now
magnus goes queen captures on g8 ding
also picks up a rook
knight captures on a1 but now for the
final time
pause the video and find another winning
idea for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on paying
attention as
we've already hinted this and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
eliminate the defender of the d7 square
so queen
captures an e8 a temporary queen
sacrifice
uh after which uh yeah it was in this
position on move 24 that
dingle and resign the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh you're up so much material there's no
good move for black here like you could
you could do you could do whatever you
you want but
nothing really suffices uh like if you
capture then just knight d7 check forks
the king and the queen and after this
uh or whatever you're just gonna capture
or even better here so you can recapture
with the king
uh captures captures and now that's just
it will capture some a1 you are up a
whole year up a whole piece
uh and without without much compensation
and
on the other hand after this queen
captures an e8 move you could play
something like f captures an e5
grab this piece but then just queen e7
and still now you're
not uh you're not really doing uh all
that much here for example knight to b3
or to c2 doesn't
it doesn't really matter you're gonna go
bishop d6 check you're gonna win this
point you're gonna win this pawn
and it's just a very ugly position for
example king e8 we're going to go bishop
captures on e5
and well not not much
not much to be done here uh i mean you
could continue it but
it's uh not not something to
to to continue because how is this
knight coming
into the game like this is covered by
the queen this is covered by the queen
covered by the bishop covered by the
pawn so one simple move like roxy one
will simply eliminate it so it's not
even not even possible to continue this
uh so
after this queen captures on e8 uh being
resigned and
magnus equalizes the match and i will
spoil the result a little bit
games three and four were drawn so they
have to go into blitz tie breaks but
we're gonna see what happens there
and most likely cover some of those
games as well
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
a mystery person andrew darcy leslie ali
and uh
yvette meyer and andrew wilson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to cover
uh these uh miniatures from the magnus
crossing grand final checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
sunday